it is a movie that is a spectrum of
feeling it is a spectacle it's a film
that is about a brother and sister at
its core but it is also about them
trying to reclaim some of their Heritage
and some of the legacy of their family
their Hollywood horse trainers and
they're also after a impossible shot of
a UFO
this
is nope no I'm just kidding I just felt
like
[Music]
from the get-go trying to make a movie
that would I would have loved when I was
14. and not and specifically a movie
that I just wouldn't understand how it
could be done that's kind of where it
started for me and it ended up becoming
about the idea of spectacle the
addiction to spectacle the idea that a
spectacle can be bad
you know there's certain entities in
this world that giving them attention
is the exact wrong thing to do
yet we'll we'll go down that path
Humanity has this one issue and I have
it as well
it's one of the nicest feelings to be in
control of something but there is in a
way nothing more euphoric than
being absolutely not in control of
something and that thing presents itself
to be
much nicer than you would envisioned you
know we had Ambitions where we started
to set out for this film that sort of
wouldn't allow us to shoot
certain scenes at night because
the technology simply doesn't really
exist we started to experiment just very
early
and we started building Rigs and we
started testing and we
started seeing Merit in it you can see
color you could see color you could see
depth you could see space so you could
see the sky you could see much more than
you normally would see in in films and
big big night setups
the run is an amazing scene because it's
where we really see the excitement we
feel of really risking Our Lives to go
after something that could be really
amazing and you finally see what the
plan is that they've been cooking up and
how incredible it's going to be to
capture the entity
creating horror and you know suspense
with a creature is to really engage the
audience's imagination it was really
about not necessarily showing everything
you need to be able to design it and
control it so the audience will look at
it and be terrified by it you know and
after the audiences I've seen the movie
we really want them to look at the sky
differently anytime you see a cloud in a
film it's not real you know it's it's
for the entire film we always made them
how do we make something absolutely
realistic that's you know the audience
will actually never notice
it's a part of the movie we you know we
knew we were building
um towards a big Climax and then we knew
that this climax had to defeat this the
sort of Slow Burn nature of the first
half of the movie in the scene we see OJ
um making this decision to ascend to
become something of the spectacle
himself the ultimate trainer the
ultimate stunt man trying to catch the
impossible it really is the first time
that all characters
are managing to bring gin jacket down
onto the ground and give the audience a
clear Glimpse at it to see really that
jean jacket was not a solid object it's
a wind creature in a way and it's it's a
master at moving in its environment and
you know the way it moves the way we
reveal it you know was extremely
important
Michael's work in the in the whole film
but in this Final Act I felt like it's
so climactic and has an awareness of
film genre and Trope and sweepingness
and and but also brought a sincerity and
an earnestness to my work that hasn't
been brought out in my work yet what you
hear underneath it is the warm Family
theme of the relationship between OJ and
M and the legacy of their dad and then
at the end of it finally when the
standoff comes between OJ and the entity
it turns very strong and you feel his
resolve and you feel the stakes
heightening and the orchestra crescendos
I hope it's a really memorable cinematic
moment
foreign
holy [ __ ] I think it's taking the
dancers are you getting this
guys OJ's headed up he's gonna run OJ's
going to run
hey it's gone I can't see it anymore
guys
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I think why it works is because it calls
on several different ideas that are part
of the film naturally it's it's really
exciting it's big music there's so much
going on it's got that sense of sounding
a bit like a western like a horse
Galloping it's some of the densest music
I've ever written there's percussion and
there's full Orchestra and there's a
beat and everything and the last thing
it has in it that Jordan always really
loves is that at the end it goes and
then there's Dead Silence
and the silence where you can suddenly
hear the sound design and you can you're
just left with your own emotions it's
it's that kind of negative space if you
will is as important as the bigness of
the music itself so exciting to be you
know putting sound on something where
really you're you're not necessarily
looking at it you're the sound you know
we the audience are going to sit there
alongside the characters and experience
it and get our information from what
we're hearing first time ever for me
that you get little edits back and
they have been worked on by you with
extremely clear idea while we're
shooting the film
which is very interesting because of
course your sound design also started to
feed back to us working out in the field
we sort of discussed the use of wind and
how it could become useful and then I
was like look what I've got
and I've read your amazing scripts and
thought hang on a minute I can send you
some ideas here
that was uh the beginnings of um
understanding how it wins and the little
fine tuning of pitches in winds could
become an interesting screen thing and
everybody here we're not we're not just
making a movie we were all kind of
creating this monster together and and
so that's why there's sort of the inter
communication was important because we
we knew we had a monster to create that
had to be horrifying and beautiful but
we also knew that we were going to be
sort of tapping what everybody sort of
finds to you know Michael's doing the
soul you know guillaume's doing the the
look of it John is doing the sound
hoyt's doing our and he's using the
empty plates the empty plates you're
doing our inability to catch it you know
it's like
um so all these pieces that are coming
together and all these conversations are
as we're going and forming what jean
jacket is becoming the the creature
design was like all departments
collaborating to kind of make this thing
make sense a lot of the credit to the
design belongs to Guillaume and his team
as well you start to realize that the
whole surface is kind of soft basically
it's made of like a material that is
incredibly light and deforms you know
like sales you know on the on on the
ship we kind of pretty much broke all
the rules of creature design you know
like it's like there's no head there's
no arms there's no tentacles there's no
you know there's nothing that that you
know the audience is used to seeing very
early on you know I think quite said you
know he yeah but it has to make physical
sense you know it has to work in physics
and I'm you know I'm thinking that's
impossible
but it was a good it was a good starting
point because it became this Mantra I
know uh it has to feel like it's in
front of us first and foremost if it
feels real we've done something
the big unveiling of jean jacket we're
showing OJ and emerald who are across
along this massive distance trying to
communicate and non-verbally set up a
plan to train to Wrangle this thing it's
a moment of climax for the characters a
moment unique in my films it's sort of
traditional it's meant to make you feel
something different than what I usually
uh want to feel so very unique moment
for me and then of course on on just in
scope I don't think I've ever tried to
handle a scene or a set this big jean
jacket is revealing that it's a
spectacle that is is beautiful the very
nature of it is hard to look away from
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
was is one of the first thing we
designed on the movie because we you
know in terms of design process we first
designed how jean jacket would look in
its unfolded form and then
re-engineered Hollywood's kind of form
back into you know what looks like a
flying saucer gin jacket is a completely
structured uh creature completely made
of like
billowing cloth in the wind and when he
fully expands it's it's a 480 feet wide
creature it's probably one of the
largest Club simulation with bulu we've
ever made it's kind of like when you see
a peacock suddenly you know his tail is
falling and suddenly the the tail
completely unfurls it's something that
is mesmerizing beautiful unexpected
threatening at the same time there's a
green square Motif or not the idea of
money the box that money puts us in it
says is there any way to get can we get
this green Square in there and so he
goes away for a couple few days and he
came back with this really
um you know perfect
sort of scary idea of how to uh how to
interpret that into this this sort of
eye lore thing it wasn't because now
jean jacket in the final scene is really
showing off and it's like okay I need to
put on a dance and so we would I think
we were looking at peacock sounds and
and then I was so for peacock's making
that noise when it's showing off how can
I make if I've made a scream into a win
maybe I can make a peacock sound into a
wind and that was the kind of process of
shaping that big Roar at the end is that
a slowed down bird sound that is exactly
that is that is yeah that's a peacock I
mean if you turned it if you sped it up
but it wouldn't be quite as impressive
it's not it's nothing more than it
so much about this film specifically is
is about film and it's about going back
to before there were VFX and to the very
first pieces of trickery and so you know
where these techniques all kind of like
fall together is does really feel like a
celebration of movies and and that's
kind of what was pushing us forward
through this thing nothing ever bits
reality you know it's like if you can do
it for real nothing will ever look
better than the real thing White had
this great idea he said let's call my
friend Craig who's the best helicopter
pilot in the world he can create this
practical dust and then what Guillaume
and and and his team were able to do is
use that that real dust and integrate
the the V effect saucer with that
well these are the the scenes I think
where certainly for in my work I feel
like we we open up the aperture no pun
intended and find ourselves in an epic
that looking back on it I don't
understand how these people pulled it
off to be quite honest
both of them become a hero but uh
different Heroes than we thought they
would embracing his greatness in a way
that we didn't expect the character
could and she's making a selfless act
and ultimately stopping to defend the
legacy of her her home and the ranch
even though it's a matter of spirit at
this point and not of a personal gain
I think both these scenes are really
great examples of the power of music to
elevate a story to a place that it's
epic it was really important that a film
that's shot in IMAX and these
unbelievable effects really finally
become Larger than Life when we see the
entity in all of its size and it was
really thrilling to be able to finally
go all out and really bring that for a
size of movie that nope is generally
when I'm making a movie I'm trying to
celebrate you know I'm trying to
celebrate life I'm trying to celebrate
film how to celebrate people trying to
celebrate my audience but they they
always I think will come with a sense of
responsibility of pointing out something
that I I don't see pointed out
chase the impossible shot
[Applause]
[Music]